hey Dello says Chelsea wants to get
married but doesn't want to but does she
want to be married AKA The Wedding good
respectful chat by the way Rich thanks
so
that's an interesting uh statement it's
like you want to be sorry you want to
get married but do you want to be mayor
have you ever
um I think you said you've been single
for the last two or three years was it
yeah like last two years you've had a
long-term relationship
um the longest was two years yeah okay
so you're what was it 30 or 29 you're 31
right
there's 31. so what so what's stopping
you
um from keeping guys around like over a
long-term basis like what do you think
is missing from the equation where
it's not working out right because
otherwise you'd have been married by now
right
for me once around that like one year
mark I very much know what I want like
whether I want to continue with that
person or not
um but as I've gotten older to my
standards get higher and I cut people
off earlier than I used to just because
issues that come up in the beginning
they always end up being constant issues
or growing later on yeah
but also what I've found I like and need
has changed as I've gotten older and
the list gets longer of what I'm looking
for so what are the red flags because I
mean like you said you're very picky to
some degree so I get I guess you've got
some red flags for guys I mean I've got
a red flag list for guys to vet women on
that I get criticized for so do you have
like a red flag list that you've sort of
compiled or thought of as you're dealing
with guys and why they're not a good fit
on a long-term basis yeah
um one thing I've noticed is guys I've
started talking to they can be kind of
aggressive right off the bat or trying
to be controlling to some type of way
give me an example look something that
stands out
something like if I ever have to travel
for work they have an issue with it
um how do they express the issue
it's just they start rule making
comments of like oh you're gonna find
someone when you're gone or like
something like that
um are you traveling with Steve from
accounting and sharing a hotel room or
no no you just you just
anxious about you traveling without
being around
yeah that turns you off so that's a red
flag
yeah I also don't like guys who are very
clingy right off the bat
so I'm not clingy off the bat but clingy
later on
yes as long as
I can still do what I want to do on my
own time I like having my space and some
guys don't get that
okay
what do they what are they doing where
you're getting the vibe that they don't
get it
um like if I some guys they want to hang
out like every single day and I'll just
be tired I have work I have to wake up
early
and it's I have to keep saying that and
they don't get it
okay so what else you got on that red
flag list
[Music]
um
one thing I've noticed is like with
social media like
uh if I start getting
women that are watching my stories a lot
and they're tied to this guy I'll ask
them about it because women don't
usually unless they know them they don't
usually watch my stuff or anything and
it's always a lie to some degree like
recently it was oh I don't even know
this person blah blah blah and then he
unfollowed her or blocked her or
something
and this girl lived where he's from well
he went back home and I happened across
her page he was following her again and
I'm like okay so on this guy's going on
there
okay so you think he's got something
going on in the background with her or
she's acting yeah
yeah like girlfriend or something like
that like
I
don't mess with any drama or games so
okay so you okay
um and what are the red flags you have
um
someone who's very like I'll say my
piece with them like maybe I'm not
feeling it like they are maybe I need
some more time and they just keep
pushing it like I don't really checked
out at that point like that's not really
a
like a disqualifier like they've already
been disqualified it's just now they're
bugging you
yeah
like even if I was going to be patient
with it it's like third
yeah
you know but I mean like you know when
you know right like there's this concept
of genuine burning desire which I talked
about in the third chapter of my book
and I'm again the book's more so geared
towards men but it's like if you have
genuine burning desire for somebody
um you're not gonna be like yeah I need
a little bit of time I'm not sure like
you know you know right it's like a
frying pan to the forehead like this is
the this is it right so
that's more of an annoyance they've
already been disqualified do you have
any other like major red flags that
you're dealing with on a consistent
basis
um
I guess saying one thing and doing
another
like they want to keep seeing you
um they want to see where it goes they
want to get to know you and then they
never
they won't respond for days on end
um there's always excuses or they like
say that this was going on
you have a conversation or whatever and
you don't hear for them for at least
another week
just not adding up yeah okay I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out